this is going to be a little bit of a
weird story but i have to get to it
laura ingram's show the other night
raymond arroyo is on
and they do
they have a discussion
where there seems to be some confusion
between the host and the guest
and the liberal media went crazy over
this
you know i was watching an episode of uh
you where measles came up
wait wait when did i mention measles
i don't know it was on you
wait
[Music]
what was on me what are you talking
about right what is it even hearing what
i'm saying i never had the measles
what's on you
we never did
we never did a measles and vaccine
episode is this a joke i don't even know
what you're talking about it was on you
it was on youtube i've never had raymond
i've never had measles what are you
talking about this is stupid it was an
episode of a show
laura what's it called
you
you it's called you i've never done a
show on measles i i just completely give
up we gotta get it it's a show i give up
called you on netflix
there's a show called lowering on
netflix
i'm moving on to adele i can't explain
this to you the pop singer all right so
this is obviously a bit they're doing
who's on first okay and whether i think
it's kind of funny but if you if you
maybe you think it's funny maybe you
don't think it's funny they're obviously
just doing who's on first i don't know
what's on first no what's on second i
don't know third base right they're just
doing that but about this this netflix
show and the left didn't get it
and the left said oh these idiots these
it's so obviously a bit
but they didn't look at these oh my gosh
i can't believe this craziness that
the takeaway from it
is not whether or not you know this is
the funniest bit in the world the
takeaway is the left
does not understand the right at all
they don't get it they think we're so
dumb and evil and they just like so
don't
get what we're saying and what we
believe and you and you're seeing this
play out right now in the
trial of kyle written ash you're seeing
it play out everywhere where the the
facts are sort of secondary to the left
just imposing their will without even
considering what the right has to say
i'm glad you like that clip hold up
obviously subscribe ring the bell you
know get the notifications on youtube
but what you got to do here's what you
got to do you got to go to ample
podcasts spotify stitcher google play
wherever you get your audio podcasts
subscribe
to the michael knowles show
m-i-c-h-a-e-l canada l-e-s
l-e-s-s-h-o-w subscribe leave a
five-star review we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]